but I did it best been a ball Hulk
that's what I do just a ball hog man the
ball in the air is mine I don't care who
watching who thinks it's theirs I'm
going to take it no matter what that
ball is mines it's just a great pick
right here I mean this wasn't the
coverage but I seen an Open Door seen
the quarterback I stayed locked on on
them so I thought I did the best they
did the quarterback to throw me to pick
learning from somebody that got to go
jacket is special I mean that play right
there he told me that I just had the
instance to go get the ball take the
ball away I mean he told me I seen the
receiver close enlightment ain't nothing
else coming back that way unless they
running a mesh but they didn't run a
mesh my dude ran inside picked the line
back and tried to get the running back
out but coach primer already taught me
that he told me that months ago it's
just something that I replayed in my
head in the middle of the game my
receiver tight he's either going under
or he's running the out route he took an
inside release so I know he's going
under watch the back come out they did
the quarterback pick the ball off